[Music]
but first developing tonight one man is
dead after being shot at an apartment
complex just east of the strip
this happened around six o'clock tonight
madison kimbrough is live near the strip
with the latest details madison
yes this happened at emerald suites
right off of paradise road and elm drive
now this is what we know so far
the person who was shot was a black man
in his mid-20s and he was rushed to a
nearby hospital
where he later died metro revealed that
the victim arrived at emerald suites
with a friend
to meet the suspect the victim was in
the parking lot with the suspect
for a brief time before the man shot and
killed the victim
the friend then went and flagged down
police
we do know that a thin black male in his
who appears to be in his
mid early 20s was seen fleeing the
suspect vehicle
after the shooting occurred so that's
what we're looking for at this point
metro says the victim did not live at
the complex may continue to talk to
witnesses
metro police is asking anyone with
information to please come forward
you can remain anonymous by calling
crime stoppers we'll of course keep you
updated with more information on 8 news
now and 8 news now dot com
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now